hello i'm hannah k and welcome to this
emergency intelligence squad event on
the resignation of boris johnson
we're very uh grateful and honored that
simon jenkins and jonathan friedland
have been able to take part at such
short notice we've just heard johnson's
resignation statement so i'm going to
hand straight over to our chair she is
an investigative journalist and podcast
host on the times and sunday times she
is manvin
rana hello and welcome to this
intelligent squared event on what is
by any measure an extraordinary day in
british politics we'll be reflecting on
the resignation of the prime minister
boris johnson and a government in an
unprecedented crisis
and in order to do that we're joined by
two brilliant journalists and
westminster watchers to discuss the
momentous events of recent days and what
we might expect to happen over the
coming hours days and weeks
we're joined firstly by jonathan
friedland who is a guardian columnist
and author who's also a past winner of
the orwell prize for journalism he also
presents bbc radio 4's contemporary
history series the long view as well as
two podcasts politics weekly america for
the garden and unholy alongside the
israeli journalist janet mibi we're also
joined today by simon jenkins who's also
a guardian columnist and author and a
former editor of the evening standard
and the times we're really delighted you
could both join us today now this event
is going to run for an hour and for the
first half i'm going to be in discussion
with jonathan and simon and then we'll
be taking some of your questions and i
imagine on a day like today you'll have
a few so if you want to do start asking
them now by clicking on the q and a
button
at the bottom of the screen and we'll
try to get through as many as possible
if you want us to use your name please
do add that to your question um before
you press send
jonathan and simon
what a day i think we can we can finally
put the old adage of the week as a long
time in politics away because it feels
like we've lived several lifetimes in
just the last few hours we've just seen
boris johnson stand up outside downing
street and deliver his resignation
speech amid booze that you could hear
from the the public gathered outside um
simon what did you make of it
well uh
these eccentric occasions they don't
often happen um one inevitably compares
them with other such occasions um uh
i think theresa may was tearful margaret
thatcher was tearful um boris johnson
was characteristically boisterous almost
um uh he couldn't stop sort of
bellyaching a bit about the the herd
moves in and all those sort of races um
he's very disappointed very upset um but
i think as far as that goes uh we we
almost say good luck to him i mean he he
went out with good grace let's put it
that way
he didn't show much contrition
when did he ever
he doesn't do contrition uh i i i it is
really one of his great i mean it is it
was his undoing this inability to show
contrition um to show self-doubt i mean
it's very important in a politician we
must i think touch politicians by other
light sometimes self-confidence is vital
you have to believe in yourself you have
to believe what you're doing is the
right thing to do you have almost to
believe that everybody else is doing the
wrong thing
but the one thing you don't do is say
sorry very often
uh i think it's a shortcoming in a
politician but it's typical
jonathan what did you make of the speech
now i too was struck by that bullishness
and the contrast with um theresa may's
uh tearful departure um
even actually i remember when gordon
brown did his which was admittedly
an exit organized by the electorate
rather than by the
his fellow con uh party
mps
you could tell he too was pretty
emotional about doing it instead boris
johnson was it was no different from one
of his
campaign appearances you know it was a
bullish and a b to simon says
um
and that it speaks to a kind of
hollowness in boris johnson i think i
mean you know people have often wondered
what's there underneath the mask and
underneath the sort of bluff exterior
and the answer is not that much i think
and so um he wasn't able really to do
much more than his usual shtick
in a way i too clocked the digs
at others the uh line about accusing
them of being essentially a stampeding
herd
as if the reason for his departure was a
wave of hysteria that had caught up his
his naive and
bovine colleagues uh who'd been caught
up in this um
and
and so therefore that go that's the
other side instantly of no contrition
because there was no hint it was
anything to do with him
uh instead it was just a change in the
weather that happens
and he did that usual thing he's always
done because he does like crafting his
own narrative which is he sought to
write his own headline with this line
them's the breaks you know he wants that
to be that you know he's he's taking the
sun and mirror sub-editors jobs for them
and thinking put that in there
as if fate under did him
nothing to do
uh with him and i think that's you know
in a way
one of the reasons as i think simon
mentioned for his undoing it did sound
as if he was blaming the party and still
felt the public was on side
despite the booze you could hear from
the street
yes i mean
sorry you you go ahead some
i mean i i i
i i didn't see he could do anything else
i mean he had fought to stay
uh beyond the bounds of dignity uh he
humiliated himself i think over the past
24 hours and he was trying to recover
some of that dignity i think um in part
by referring to what his what is his
basically his entire
ruling narrative um it's not the party
it's me
i am the person who got you into power
like like you've been in power i am the
person who appealed to a new slab of
voters on the labor side and i'm popular
i i'm those people outside in the street
they're my people even they're booing
now um so um so you know that that that
is me
and i think i think that it's almost
understandable that he should say why
was he trying to stay and stay in power
he stayed in power because he felt he
had a mandate to do so
and jonathan while talking about his his
great love for the public and the public
he's met you know he was also promising
to to keep the country going until
somebody is appointed to take his place
i mean does that sound like he still
thinks he's going to hang on until about
the autumn or should we be thinking
about other caretakers i mean what
happens now
i think there is something
uh
in that uh
notion of him saying i want more time uh
that in a normal politician you would
think okay he's just talking about being
a caretaker but with him
you do have to wonder what he's up to
and i think um the thought that he is up
to something there
is potent because
uh he he's one of those people my
colleague our colleague raphael bear
earlier today said that he's like one of
those um
highly competitive athletes who thinks
even if the scoreline is massively
against them lopsidedly against them and
there's only 20 seconds left of the game
he thinks so long as you're still
playing you haven't lost and you might
still have a chance uh something could
come up and i think there's something in
that with boris johnson that he thinks
okay october
you know let's see let's see what if you
live to fight another day
um who knows what can happen
and that's one of the reasons by the way
i think the you know his colleagues are
saying no we've got to actually get him
out you saw dominic cummings has tweeted
in the last few hours saying it'll be
carnage
classic cummings language it'll be
carnage if you let him stay
because he will do all kinds of things
he'll make mischief he'll appoint people
he'll start new policies etc to make it
impossible to remove him or make it more
difficult to remove him so you know
people have already forgotten that of
course theresa may stayed as prime
minister
only three years ago while the tories
found a new leader no one uh
raised even an eyebrow that because
people knew that she would abide by the
unspoken conventions
he doesn't even abide by the spoken
conventions you know so he's not going
to
uh play this game normally and that is
why people who know him well are
thinking
you know get the removal men in right
now because otherwise who knows what
this guy is capable of so jonathan what
are you hearing what does happen next
you know i know that there's lots of
talk of dominic raab for example
potentially stepping in um
what what does yes i mean
but well they they have to get they
would have to get borisson to agree to
there being some kind of interim or
acting prime minister they would you
know that person would have to go and
see the queen and that you can't be half
you know half pregnant when it comes to
being prime minister you would have to
be
sworn in as it were as prime minister
and a visit to the palace and so on and
so there boris johnson still has some
leverage i mean just because he would
have to agree to that so what do you
what happens the the 1922 committee uh
will meet on monday and arrange these an
election for a new executive they could
as their very first act say we're having
a vote of no confidence people talk
about having it on tuesday you know who
knows they could say we'll have it right
now but let's say they did it on tuesday
and it would be done by tuesday night
and that could say
the upshot of that could be
instant departure you have to go now um
but it's difficult because that is about
the all the 1922 committee has sway over
is the role of leader of the
conservative party which job boris
johnson has resigned from now
the job of prime minister it's more
complicated you know that is that's
that's not in the gift of the 1922
committee so you're into quite
constitutionally murky water water which
normally no one ever had to really
navigate because no one tested it and
you know peter hennessy says that we've
relied on the good chap theory of
government and until boris johnson you
could rely on that but he may he doesn't
he's not a good chair and he won't he
won't follow those rules so you know
it's not it's not a done deal
i mean simon that that is one of the
things that's become really
apparent in in this whole sagi you know
waking up this morning
there was a sense that nobody quite knew
how this would end boris johnson might
just have refused to leave altogether
you know has this really tested the
limits of our constitution
what would we have done if he if he
hadn't
issued this resignation speech well i i
think we're being a bit overdramatic
here
i mean there have been messy
resignations the essence of
parliamentary democracy is is often
messiness that
we don't have fixed terms we don't have
a simple system whereby the president
writes a cavalcade up to the
constitutional whatever it is um you you
have to accept that this these things
are not
often dignified in many ways teddy's
departure wasn't very dignified um
i mean certainly
theresa mays wasn't very dignified even
david cameron's is a bit odd and i i
think we just got to accept that this is
a bit messy um i genuinely don't think
boris is scheming or plotting something
um
anything is possible but
yeah i slightly think it's one notch
below scheming and plotting it's it's
more just that sense of
ultra competitive man who thinks
you never know
and and it's better to be in than out um
but i agree i mean the tenor of his
speech today was one of somebody who is
eyeing the exit
but he's not going to do it quick i also
think by the way very trivial point but
one worth remembering
is
politicians senior politicians are much
more obsessed than you think they would
be by the stats by the record book and
if boris johnson leaves on tuesday he
would have been a shorter serving prime
minister than theresa may uh he will be
briefer than her and she is regarded as
a byword for failure among conservatives
there will be a piece of him that thinks
give me two or three more weeks so i can
have been in office longer than she was
that's all it needs
and then then i'll go and if you think
that's trivial i remember talking to
people around tony blair in 2006 7 who
said
he wants to have done 10 years 10
calendar years may the first 2007 will
mean 10 years then he'll be up and you
think that's just a date on a calendar
why does it matters to these people and
their egos it matters so i think he
would like to out
live
in a way um we know that boris johnson
has always sort of looked towards you
know his um uh his sail ability as you
know sort of a columnist and and i guess
a a public speaker in the future uh does
he also need to sort of improve his exit
does he need to make it look a little
bit better before he steps down in order
to make sure he gets the speaking gigs
he's hoping for in the future
is that for simon um
jonathan why didn't you um
there's been a lot of really interesting
discussion about that um in the last
48 hours or so and
interesting because conflicting um andy
coulson uh who knows a thing or two
about comms and spin he was a former
editor of the news of the world and spin
doctor for
um david cameron before things became a
game came a cropper a bit uh he
um has written that you know boris
johnson has always been a teller of
tales and a crafter of narratives and
his view is his view is that the
dramatic chaotic exit makes for a better
story and a more saleable memoir than a
nice orderly calm teresa may star exit
on the other that's one view i mean
you know that it's he's he's made a bit
of history it's more dramatic it's more
historic
etc then on the other hand you talk to
and as i did actually just yesterday
somebody pretty senior in publishing who
thinks the uh johnson memoir is
radioactive at the moment and very few
publishers would want to go
near it it says this source because
um he's he's just a sort of toxic brand
um right now and that what he needs to
do runs this advice is to
take some time out maybe do you know
just just let some time pass perhaps on
the back benches perhaps doing you know
he could do work on his shakespeare
biography or whatever and
leave some time for the memoir so who's
right the publishing guy or andy coulson
you know i leave it to our um our very
well-informed audience to weigh that one
up i suppose also for speaking gigs
particularly the ones abroad um you know
sort of people like tony blair has had a
great reputation in america for example
you did wonder in the last 24 hours what
the rest of the world must make of us
watching what's happening with this sort
of um you know it's a truculent prime
minister who's refusing to leave um
how do we look on the world stage well
interesting because i i i did an
interview just yesterday with an
american tv network and what surprised
me was their sense that this was all
actually a bit eccentric and british and
funny because they said oh you know
boris
donald trump
was guilty of this terrible abuse of
power where he wanted to overturn an
election whereas your guy is being
driven from office because he had a
birthday party with the slice of cake
you know isn't that what it's all about
and
not you know we know not really um but
it fitted a sort of amusing britain you
know defenestrating a leader over a tea
party um
not you know that wasn't fully
understood but that's interesting if
that's the perception
um rather than being seen as i think you
know his critics here see him as being
on a par with or in the same camp as a
donald trump victor orban etc this
populist who with contempt for rule of
law
it seems the boris persona the kind of
clownish amusing buffoon persona
has somehow
lived on in the united states but but
one thing i thought was noticeable from
his resignation speech that did make me
think he's got an eye on his future was
the big chunk he dedicated to ukraine
and i think that was
with an eye on the lecture circuit in
mind where he's thinking
i'm treated as a hero there they love me
there and that's a platform on which to
build that is the bit of his reputation
isn't toxic around the world because
there's very few takers for brexit
internationally it's not seen as a great
idea or a big success um but if the
savior of ukraine
you know he'll get speaking gigs in
levith and then from there he can heath
i'm guessing he will think okay i can
turn that into gigs in um you know
louisiana
and st louis after that
simon i mean not just boris johnson's
reputation on the world stage but what
is it what's it done for us you know as
a country how do you think britain has
viewed after the last 24 hours
uh i don't know can you hear me all
right
yes sorry i lost you um
it's a moot point and there's no doubt
at all that boris johnson had the most
extraordinary personality he did
communicate to people in ways that that
traditional politicians often didn't
he's very very popular in ukraine um i
know when he's in america he's very
popular with with many of the people who
met in america
he is very good in a crowd
and i think to an extent
um he sort of galvanized our public
image um in the greek theory when he's
in charge that said um the the
relentlessness of the bad news coming
out of darling street absolute
relentlessness left american friends of
mine completely amazed and they they
really couldn't understand what had
happened
so i think at the end of it he'll be
seen as an episode as a spasm of
populist politics
possibly i i hesitate to make odious
comparisons but a bit like donald trump
a moment when the political system stood
on its head did something unusual um
surprised us all
uh entertained us all in a certain way
uh as know a cure is the inappropriate
time to do that i may say um but uh you
you can't dictate these things i do
think he'll be a blip and i rather i
rather fear that that the return of the
tedium and the doldrums often
jonathan is there something in that you
know trump always called him britain
trump um
is he what was we are there great
parallels
well there are you know there as always
with these things there are and there
aren't i mean the there aren't in the
sense that he's just given a resignation
speech today without threatening to
unleash a violent mob to ensure he's his
own uh i think even he he would not
cross that line
and
you know they were the the
um there was definitely you know a vein
of racist prejudice that ran through
boris johnson's writings about you know
muslims black women old black black
people muslim women and so on uh
and you can point to those in the
writings
i don't think he weaponized race uh in
the way that um
donald trump did um but the things that
are in common
uh and we saw them even today actually
is this populist contempt for
rules for conventions for democratic
norms for the rule of law this claim
that he speaks and embodies the will of
the people that his critics are somehow
uh against the will of the people
despite a super privileged background
himself offering himself as a tribune of
them of the masses against the elite i
mean in boris johnson's case it's such
nerve it's such a cheek to pose that way
when you know he is absolutely a child
of the establishment and the elite but
nevertheless that's the appeal and the
central thing the defining
is this uh disregard contempt actually
for truth and that is what made them
twins across the atlantic it is what
borum donald trump saw i think it's why
he saw
boris johnson as something of a kindred
spirit because
they both had that that willingness to
just lie and lie and lie and not even
you know break stride while doing it i
mean just to say whatever was helpful
for that minute even if it was untrue
and it is proven to be boris johnson's
undoing i mean it isn't just that he
appointed
a man and serially accused of sexual
misconduct as his deputy chief whip it's
that he lied about his claim
of ignorance of that record claim not to
have been specifically told when he had
and um
you know that part the this of course i
think would have been survivable had it
not been for partygate before
and part of the gate turned again on
lies it was the deception the line that
did it and that is what the two of them
absolutely have in common i i i think we
have to be slightly careful there um
i don't regard boris johnson donald
trump um the lies that he told were what
i would like to call procedural lies um
they were saying
the ability to say half the truth and
keep your fingers crossed behind your
back uh as against donald trump's
monumental lies um
by the thousand boris it seems to me is
a slightly different phenomenon uh he's
a bit like um so
he's a he's a tough liar
the lies aren't desperately important um
they're somehow unavoidable and he
always thinks he can get away with them
but but um i don't think it's the lies
that undid him really i think it's it's
a triviality and undoubtedly the sleaze
which which really undid him but the
feeling that he was in office to look
after his friends um
to to to to reward his allies uh to
disregard ability to disregard
competence a general feeling that he was
he was blowing the dignity of his office
uh and i think that that is what really
undid him i mean people fasten on their
lives because the lies are fact
these other things are much more nuances
of office um and i do think i do think
because i think it's now as a moment we
might at least be a little charitable
and i do think that the the the charm
the ability to persuade people he's a
good chap even if he isn't um the fact
that wherever boris went people tended
to smile they cheered up a bit um he's
given politics a sort of a lesson in
lift which very very few politicians in
britain although many abroad do and it's
the populist in him uh i don't think
populism as such is an evil thing it's
an evil thing when it's abused but i do
think he showed us um that popularity in
a politician um is a matter of
personality and style uh and it did it
did deliver for him for let's say for
three years
so he this is why guardian readers do
delight in our paper because guardian
writers often see the world very very
differently um i do disagree quite
strongly with all of that i mean partly
because i think it's
um sam makes a really interesting point
about charisma and an appeal and i
absolutely agree with him that he had
that uh boris johnson by the bucket load
that people will come take away from
this anything positive about that i
think the opposite will happen i think
people will
uh
run a mile from the idea of i don't
think voters by the way but i mean other
politicians and others will think
this is not a model to follow because he
will be a warning uh he'll be a
cautionary tale about the power of the
charismatic leader yes people will say
this guy can crack a joke or this woman
can deliver a good speech but look where
that got us last time you know um he was
because boris johnson was that was all
he was he was all performance all stick
all charisma
um it will be a warning don't be fooled
again by that because even with a i mean
let's just think on this even with an
80-seat majority he's unraveled and the
government itself is is is a breaking
point
um that's an amazing thing to do and
that's because of in a way that that all
he had was
performance and shallowness so i think
he's he's going to serve as an
advertisement against those that suite
of political skills i'd also say just
something about populism i mean i think
this idea that he's a tough liar
he's in a way what helps him and it's a
very british thing which is we don't
really realize when someone
is a kind of victor orban figure or a
donald trump figure because they sound
and look like one of the good to one of
the chaps and he had that eaten accent
and so we didn't think we couldn't think
of him as a sinister sort of bolsonaro
type figure or whatever but it was a
mistake because there were big lies
there and i would say too
one is i think brexit is a project
founded on big lies the lie that 350
million on the side of the bus but also
that we could stop trading in a free
trade area with our closest neighbors
and it would somehow make us richer
massive lie
but also partygate wasn't about the bits
and pieces about partying
it was about saying to people these are
the rules we're all following them these
are life and death rules that will
deprive you of contact with your loved
one
and i'm laughing behind my hand because
i'm not keeping them at all that's
there's nothing tough about that lie or
gentle about that lie that was a really
deep attack i think on on how people
lived and made really grave decisions
where they said i'm not going to bid
farewell to my dying father or mother
because the rules don't let me and they
are now two years later and they will
for years forever think i was a fool
because of
what that man was doing so i think
they're serious the lies the boris
johnson lies you know they're different
from the donald trump lies
not as serious as overturning a
democratic election but pretty great
that wasn't alive it was a hypocrisy i
think i mean they lied about it
afterwards but i think your objection in
general to this populist
question is is very sophisticated and
i'm i'm not totally sure it bites um i i
i watched boris johnson i watched nigel
farage two populist leaders of the past
ten years on the stump and i was always
very impressed by the chemistry they
produced in people and i don't think the
fact that they sometimes lied about the
sometimes what might seem like
not-minded things but they were sort of
minor things um is the issue uh i don't
even think the lie about brexit it's
going to undo brexit something else only
brexit which is going to cause make our
life a misery
but i just think as long as you've got
people voting in elections for other
people
that decision is going to be complex it
has traditionally been based on um on on
money on want on deprivation on how all
these things
increasingly now we're seeing it's being
based on whether you like or find appeal
in the person who's standing for
election and i think it's it's dangerous
uh uh all i'm saying is i don't i don't
discount it i think it's very important
and i think it's something you you you
really should um take account of within
in judging johnson's brief period in
british politics simon do you think do
you think there is something about that
form of charisma that makes people
either love you or really hate you so
you know we sort of found that he was
the prime minister who reached parts of
the country that nobody else could but
when stories like partygate came to
light
it was those people who he'd reached if
he'd entertained before who really
turned against him where he did become
a toxic brand
i think i think jonathan said i think it
was partly uh something to fasten on if
you were opposed to johnson um it was
easy to fasten on uh
everybody is having small parties up and
down the country i don't know i just i
just think i think these were talisman
like the pinscher affair these are
talisman of other weaknesses you fasten
on ones that the
headline of all publicizeable um i i all
i'm really saying here is um the man had
to go i'm not defending him all i am
saying is that we need to draw the right
lessons from this period in office and i
think i think one of the things that he
brought to politics and the lesson that
we ought to learn is that this kind of
appeal
uh it it had no ideology in it no one
was i'd ever had boris saying anything
it said i will make you money or i'll
text you i'll do these things he just
smiled and joked and said stupid things
and people rose to it and i think
they'll go on doing that
unless in some sense you can find an
answer to it
jonathan how do you think we'll look
back on johnson-ism such as it is
i i think um we're in the right area
here that um
simon has steered us to i just think i
take a different view of it i think this
point about
i just want to be precise about this
term populism what to me populism means
it's not just that you're charismatic on
the stump it means that you imagine
there is some
uh conspiracy of elites against the
great mass of the people that the people
are the people's interests are ranged
against those of a self-serving
establishment or elite and that's farage
press that button johnson did as well
it is always very very effective
especially if it's channeled by a
charismatic or likable speaker but it is
sinister
and it is in even when it comes with a
charming smile and an eaten accent it is
sinister because what the for one thing
you know who's defined as the elite it
can be you know who's the who are the
few who are the many that can be shifted
and that has an unhappy history but also
it means that very soon you start having
a contempt for the rule of law for
institutions for democratic constraints
now our system in the end held boris
johnson in check but let's not forget
where he took this within two or three
months of taking office he's thought
he'd not sought he did perogue suspend
parliament because it threatened
or did stand in his way on brexit and
that took a decision of the supreme
court 11 judges to zero to say that he
what he had done was unlawful but that
was an insight into where this populist
project was going which is judges are
enemies of the people parliament should
be abolished
all rules should reside in the executive
and really we've seen it in these last
48 hours in me in one person because i
have the mandate of the people that is
has a that is a strain of politics that
has a chilling
history and is dangerous and that's what
boris johnson introduced into british
politics
yes he did it with a a very you know
winning style and a likable style
you know if you like that kind of thing
i have to say going back decades i it
didn't work on me he's not my type i
didn't like it uh you know even when he
was on a fire got news for you that
that thing of the eaton bumbling buffoon
pretending not to know the lines when
you do it doesn't work on me it doesn't
i i it leaves me cold but i know other
people like it and it worked for him but
i think you know
i hope one of the legacies is that when
someone comes to you with that
performance we start counting the spoons
we get wary because we should be wary
about that kind of performer i don't
think simon's wrong though that somehow
you know dull competent kierstama is
going to suddenly have the nation
turning uh running towards his embrace
it doesn't work like that you know some
people thought after blair everyone
would rally to gordon brown's dual
competence it doesn't really work like
that i know but i don't think we should
sort of
look on admiringly at the introduction
of that particular vein of populism into
british life well i i'm not i'm not
suggesting we admire it i'm suggesting
that if you don't analyze it properly
you won't know how to counter it um i
totally agree it is extremely dangerous
what's happening in america now i find
deeply disturbing i think america is
robust i think america will survive it
but it's going through a real period of
agony as a direct result of the sort of
populism that i was trying to describe
and you were describing now in this
country
our defense against it we don't have to
cope with presidential um primaries and
elections which is your great expertise
jonathan but what we do have is we have
tiered democracy we have parliamentary
democracy we have intermediate stages
between the electorate and the prime
minister and those intermediate stages
are absolutely vital and they are the
defense against populism in the sense in
which we're discussing it now
they are appallingly bad at reforming
themselves um if you just take one area
of british public debate at the moment
which is what we do about scotland um
northern ireland and wales um
it screams for constitutional reform of
some sort gets absolutely nowhere boris
johnson despised it he said devolution
was a mistake um we've got to find ways
of reforming these institutions
intermediate intermediate institutions
democracy if we're going to withstand
the populist menace which is a menace i
agree
simon i want to bring in some of the
questions from the audience we're
getting quite a few coming in um and
just on that question of of reform um
and where the system now stands we've
got a question here from bernard howard
who asks
johnson rewrote the rules and standards
of public life you know when one should
resign ethics proroguing parliament
has public life been irretrievably
damaged for the worse
no i just don't think so i i mean come
on now i
i i'm no fan of johnson but we've got to
keep some some things in proportion i
mean the guy did resign when the men in
grey came to see him as they
traditionally didn't make a soviet party
um
the guy did occasionally apologize what
he did wrong um most of his misdemeanors
were were not on the same scale as most
of the major issues he had to confront
in three years but what's been an
appalling time to be prime minister i
can't imagine a time outside wall
when the job of prime minister has been
more difficult than he's founded he
wasn't up to it all right but let's try
and keep it in some sort of proportion
um so i i think i think we we just need
to we need to realize where things
didn't go right we need to realize where
reform is needed and we are appallingly
bad because we haven't got a
constitution i think we're appallingly
bad at knowing where we've got to reform
that constitution and by gosh we've got
to get down to it now
jonathan do you think the standards in
public life have been eroded almost
irretrievably by by the last few years
they've been eroded
there's a question about irretrievable
um and that will partly be now and
there's a battle i think underway and
it'll be an interesting one and in some
ways the conversation simon and i and
you are having now
is parties suggest the outlines of that
and that will be this debate about his
legacy so if conservatives conclude that
this was a disaster for them that they
took a wrong turn
that they ended up trampling on a whole
lot of values they hold
dear
um
then i think it's not irretrievable
because the pendulum will swing back the
other way but if they conclude
um that you know what this kind of
worked for us actually and we yeah he
overdid it or he was he made a misstep
but otherwise this got us that big 80
seat majority and that's the way to go
and actually yeah you can rewrite the
ministerial code and you can second
ministerial advisor and you can get
um on you know
donors who are not fully disclosed to
pay for your wallpaper and and you know
push it up and get 150 a thousand quid
tree house for your kids for your child
even as you are denying free school
meals during the holidays to go those
children who would otherwise go hungry
if they think you can get away with all
of that
um you know
a conservative party that was partying
and drinking during lockdown the night
before the funeral of prince philip you
know the conservatives were meant to be
the people who didn't like all that
stuff but if they can so if they are
recoil from this period and say we must
never go back to that
this was you know we we lost our who we
are you know then i think retrievable if
on the other hand they think
yeah the the new normal um
and this becomes the new normal then i
think something
quite big will have been lost
um we've got another question here from
debbie allen asking isn't this refusal
to leave or certainly you know the
reluctance um classic trumpian behavior
is he trying to emulate trump um
and you know we've seen from january the
sixth what happens with that level of
delusion jonathan that's that's your
patch
what is this trumpian behavior is this
trumpian behavior and and could it could
it become more damaging you know perhaps
not a full-on um january the sixth style
riot but you know what more damage could
could be done in the next few months if
he hangs on yeah
and so look i think it it's not he
hasn't gone full trump because like i
said he's not summoning a mob
to downing street you know he he he
could have made a speech like that
saying you voted for me 14 million of
you and where are you and you know but
he didn't do that so that's where we had
you know simon's call for a center
perspective
is right about that that you know uh he
hasn't done that or got close to that
um
nevertheless i think if he stays in
office a long time and tries to
uh you know he was pushing things to the
to the outer limits in these last few
days where
he was losing cabinet ministers and then
just sort of
saying doesn't matter i'm going to
appoint other ones in their place i mean
if
he'd been allowed to go on much longer
and you imagine where you had ministries
unfilled
uh or people who were you know
egregiously
woefully unqualified to do those jobs
that would be bad um
so you know i i i think it's you have to
listen to his own colleagues who are
saying enough enough he needs to
be gone but i think that kind of
really uh not just undemocratic but and
you know attempts to overturn democracy
and to bring in
you know to overturn the democratic
election by violence no he's not he's
not there but you know but trump wasn't
there until the end either you know
trump got worse and worse and worse the
longer he was there so
um no i think i think
you know he's got those same populist
impulses
he doesn't think the rules apply to him
but he hasn't gone as far
simon um we've
we've got a question just sort of saying
um
what does what do you think should
happen can boris stay on as a caretaker
prime minister or does that risk drawing
great criticism and damage to the tory
party's credibility for the future um
what would you like to see happen now
i'd like to see him resign i i really do
i mean i think i think
someone not the robber or something
ought to take over as caretaker prime
minister for for three or four months um
you cannot have um half your cabinet
resigning
and have any authority at all i mean how
does a cabinet meeting be conducted when
you're surrounded by people you want him
gone or wanted him gone um it's like
facing your assassins over the dinners
you know um i i i i i it doesn't it's
not plausible and i think um i think i
think jonathan
suggested earlier what you do is you get
this process over as quickly as you
possibly can
and bundle him out but i i that the most
dignified thing frankly would be of
pentagon this week that is the tradition
they normally go the reveal man at the
back and um and the new chat comes in
the front uh we've always done it that
way and i i i
all i'm trying to say i think is that
moments like this in history you think
the earth has fallen in um i i think the
system's worked rather well uh boris
johnson hasn't been allowed to have to
stand up to hang on um he has been
forced out he's been told to go not
because the public wanted him to go he's
been told to go because the system
wanted him to go um he despised the
system he abused the system and the
system said go and he's gone uh it is
actually the system working not
necessarily very good system but it is
the system working i mean it did stretch
it to the limits it did literally take
an unprecedented number of ministers to
resign well
you only understand the system is
working when you see its limits uh i
mean become pretty close i mean the the
the great artists lessons always said
about the american constitution you
don't know it's working until it's
almost broken um and it frequently was
almost broken uh but but um
i think we need to look back just
occasionally and see are there any real
lessons we can learn from this and i
think that the
the the lessons are about how we how we
we operate the mediating institutions of
democracy which is parliament um the
lessons about how we to how we treat
populist sentiment and how we how we
report on it i mean much of this to do
with the press i mean how we publicize
people how we give them a platform don't
give them a platform um there are all
sorts of subsidiary issues that arise
out of johnson's period but on the whole
i just still think it'll be a blip
given the discussion we've had on on
populism and how boris johnson sort of
has
really um
well introduced it i suppose to the the
british system and made it sort of much
more likely option we've got a really
interesting question here from louis
johnson who asks how could we balance
the need to move away from populism
while properly addressing the deep
concerns that it seems to speak to
jonathan do you want to take that first
yes i think it's a very good question i
do think
there has to be
the only way to blunt populism of the
kind i was describing is for
the issues that drive people towards it
and the grievances or the needs rather
that drive people towards it to be
addressed so
you know when people have had decades of
in real terms fairly stagnant incomes
and wages
now they're actually going into reverse
because people because of runaway
inflation
people will begin to think the system is
somehow rigged against them when they
count up can't get
housing uh for themselves or their
children they can't you know afford to
live in their own
neighborhoods etc when they're paying a
fortune for an education that doesn't
necessarily get them a decent job at the
end and so on
um
people will be receptive to an argument
that says you know there's other people
over there who are living very well and
you're not and the system is somehow
rigged so
the system does have to well democratic
politics has to prove it can deliver
it's you know
it's no good people like me making sort
of uh you know
writing handwringing sort of earnest
columns about the importance of
democracy in the abstract people have to
feel that the democratic system delivers
for them if not
politicians who are
either contemptuous of democracy
uh as donald trump was or who play fast
and loose with democratic norms as i
think is fair to say about
um boris johnson those people will
flourish and so it really is on
i think this is part of what tony blair
is talking about a lot right now when he
sort of says you know it's for everyone
else who isn't on the extreme left or
extreme right to prove that they can
make this system
work and actually deliver for people if
they don't people are going to be very
very open to
options which um ride roughshod over
those things which i think ultimately
are really essential to protect you know
those with the least voice in our
society so rule of law sounds like a
grand issue favored by sort of qc's and
judges and hamster liberals but actually
the rule of law is what protects the
weakest against the strong
and that's an example of it but you
don't really get a hearing for that
if the weakest feel that the society
isn't really delivering for them and
they're not really getting their basic
day-to-day needs met
we've got a question here from david
matthews who asks
um
basically how will president putin be
viewing this resignation would he be
happy or sad to see boris go
i
i
i
genuinely don't think he gives a damn um
uh
we all assume that putin's sitting in
his office every morning
shaking with fear of what new sanctions
we're going to impose in him or what new
weapons we're going to send to ukraine i
just don't think he gives a damn i
really don't um
he has an extraordinary populist
following that while we're on the
subject of populism in russia we should
never underestimate it um sanctions have
no um voter sanctions have no effect on
it whatsoever um it has a deep long-term
effect on the russian economy but that's
uh that would apply in a nice responsive
democracy russia is not that um
where i do think we ought to be careful
there are um i mean we would we were
decrying the advent of populism in
britain you know plenty of populist
leaders in britain down the ages i mean
gladstone and israeli were fanatically
popular as populists um the the liberal
democrats i always think is a true
populist party um they get lots of votes
in by-elections and tend to keep them
the general elections because they've
managed to sell themselves very
successfully uh i mean we just got to be
very careful that supposing revolutions
have occurred when i
repeat myself here but i just don't
think they have occurred um we had we
had a bit of testing yes but for
goodness sake the roof hasn't fallen in
i mean i suppose it's sort of the
difference between popular and populism
where you know we have had populist
parties in the past but this sort of we
very rarely had them in power
um we've got an interesting question
here um from
um saheed hadik bite i hope i pronounced
that right saying how would you react to
those that argue the devil you know is
better than
suggesting there isn't a credible list
of potential successes
which i think is a good time really to
to find out what you think about the
runners and riders so um jonathan do you
want to go first
yeah i mean this goes to a very
interesting challenge now for labor who
were had mixed feelings about removing
boris johnson partly because they
thought he was he had become beatable
that the electoral asset had become an
electoral liability
and their problem has always been will
voters feel
uh in 2022 as they did in 1990 which is
the lead the leader we didn't like has
gone then thatcher and now boris johnson
and now there's been a change of
government then john major and now
someone else so the challenge for labor
is to sort of toxify the entire
conservative
uh party
uh brand not just and not not just let
it be sort of contained to boris johnson
and therefore they have to look at all
these next round of leaders and say
uh well they're all as uh they're all as
bad as each other um the interesting
thing is then
again it goes back to what tourists
themselves think about this period if
they are recoiling from it thinking we
must be free of any taint of it they
won't go to anybody who served in boris
johnson's cabinet and so suddenly you'll
be they'll be looking at the tom duggan
hearts and the jeremy hunts i don't
think that will happen by the way
um instead they're going to be looking
at uh the people in that circle and we
know the names of the various runners
and riders i think nadine zahawi begins
in quite a strong position
as chancellor just because that's a big
job and that's uh good sanji javid has a
kind of
he has a bit of authority because he was
the one who made the first move i think
rishi sununu has very little because he
was a follower not a leader even if it
was minutes but he should have gone in
the middle of partygate he didn't he
waited
uh and that suggests someone who's
um
lacks some of that kind of political
you know strength um that you need he's
also got that whole non-dom financial
problem you cannot be on the rich list
and be prime minister in the middle of
the cost of living crisis i don't think
um so uh you know and and then the john
major rule uh is that it's of 1990 was
that it's somebody you're not thinking
about um and it's a surprise
as it happens john major had only just
been made chancellor i think he'd been
chancellor for three months
when he became prime minister in 1990 so
that so that you know it might be worth
putting a fiver on
nadim zahawi for that reason um that's
an interesting question for the tory
party membership the one thing i would
you know whether they are ready to elect
uh
you know a muslim prime minister that's
a really interesting thing the again
untested uh there's been a
it's striking to me the last three
chancellors of this country country are
uh have the names nadine zaha rishi
sunak sajid javid that's not something
that somebody would have predicted 30
years ago but will the tory party rank
and file be happy to vote for somebody
um who fits that profile and then the
last point i would just make is whenever
there's a leadership election in the
tory party it's always been the case
that they always vote for whoever is
most anti-european it doesn't matter who
what the choice is whoever is most
anti-european tends to win and so that
would be if you apply that guy that's
why i eliminate jeremy hunt and tom
tuckenheart by the way um he won't be
one of them i don't think uh but you
know one one of that field one of that
crop jonathan you talked about him
jonathan you talked to that
highway i just wanted to check before
before we've had here from simon um do
you think in the last 24 hours has he
has he blown it at all with a rank and
file how will they view his yeah he i
agree i was i didn't want to bang on too
long i was going to give you that
parenthesis because the the thing about
him is he's potentially alienated the
pro boris people and the anti-boris
people because he's you know he's he was
the pro-virus people liked the fact
maybe that he boris johnson i should say
the pro johnson people uh that he was
prepared to take the job from johnson
somewhere like that but then he turned
on him yesterday some will dislike that
so he won't win any points that were in
he may have he may indeed have done
himself
some damage there i mean whether it can
be over uh
outweighed by what he did on vaccines
etc who knows um ben wallace looks you
know some people may feel he looks the
part but he doesn't quite have the sort
of political
chops for that i don't know i'd be
interested to hear what side of things
yeah simon who are you all runners and
writers
whenever asked this question you give a
mixed answer you partly say who you'd
like to be you don't kindly say who you
think will be and these are often not
the same people they all get mixed up in
the same menage um who would you like i
wasn't quite sure which which which side
which side
johnny was on but anyway um
i'd like to see sorry
this this is irrelevant and i think i
would like to see but you see that i
think he showed himself a considered
careful
moderate um uh unspectacular leader he's
very young um
i doubt that you'll get it you ask me
who i'd like to see um i i honestly
think apart from him they're all untried
and untested and one of the tragedies of
boris johnson possibly the greatest
tragedy of boris johnson's leadership
was his dismissal of four five six
people who would perfectly competently
take over from him and they've all gone
many of them out of parliament that was
totally outrageous and indefensible and
that's the thing i really would most
accuse him of being um as for who is
likely to get it uh i don't know i think
europe is possibly off the agenda at
long last i mean we're out of europe um
it's not very wise anyone's saying we
ought to go back in and sorry no one
needs a candidate for leadership at the
moment
but i do think the question of where you
stand on on
high public spending as against tax cuts
and so on is going to be quite critical
but again i still think probably at the
end of the day they want someone who's
likely to appeal to the electorate
and there's just very difficult to see
who it's going to be i think probably
won't be anybody we've thought of
um we've got a question here from sue
sanders
and i suppose
we are sort of coming up to the end but
i just wanted to look at this period
until there is a new leader um and
trying to work out what happens and
we've got a couple of questions about it
one from sue sanders is if boris johnson
does carry on as a caretaker what sort
of policy initiative could he kick-start
that would cause real damage in terms of
creating dissension within the tory
party or creating one of the ongoing
culture wars or you know what what are
the what are your fears for what he
might try to do during that period um
and we've got another question
um from jonathan cassian which just asks
what you know how do we manage with this
leadership vacuum until the the autumn
when we've got sort of huge issues like
ukraine cost of living crisis eu
negotiations going on um so if you want
to tackle both of those um simon do you
want to go first i it's i i find it's an
impossible question to answer because i
find it
pretty inconceivable that johnson
couldn't find himself in that position i
just think he's got to go
uh i i really i'm
in that case i mean um would you worry
about having a caretaker whether it's
dominic rob or somebody else um while
we've got sort of crises like ukraine
and and
anything anything that interim prime
minister does is gonna have to be
negotiated with his party as simple as
that
germany has been a wonderful essay in in
since since angela merkel went and
almost everything was decided by by a
bipartisan or tripod design committee of
the of the of the buddhist route it was
wonderful everybody said what what
terrific decisions they're taking um
so i i think we we ought to be trying
new things but i i don't think there's a
danger uh what the question is asking of
of some daring new initiative emerging
from an interim administration i really
don't know
jonathan
what was the second half of that there
was another question you're the
questioner
so it's um if he carries on as caretaker
um what would you worry about in terms
of politics oh yes no no i thought there
was a red meat and the
the other question from
is is just that if he doesn't carry on
if you end up with somebody like dominic
rob stepping in would you worry about
the leadership vacuum until the autumn
at a time of crisis
that was the one i wanted to get into
first um and the reason why i don't
worry is i'm quite persuaded by this
view that we haven't really had a
government for quite a long time we've
had a permanent rolling campaign
and that boris johnson was really a
uh
you know permanent
permanently in election mode he wasn't
really coming out with programs and
plans and legislation
uh that would be uh viable instead he
was just engaged in positioning and [ __ ]
drawing bright dividing lines and so on
and therefore the actual business of
governing the sort of dull business of
competent governing i didn't think
really was happening and therefore i
don't think we'd feel particularly the
gap we would actually feel a weight off
our shoulders
by having this person who's no longer
there just constantly stoking and
provoking
culture wars and i think after a while
you get very new to it and you step but
somebody who's constantly pitting this
by the way is another thing he had in
common with trump constantly pitting one
group of britons against another
is just uh you know it became part of
the sort of background noise of
day-to-day life but it's quite
um
uh debilitating it's going on all the
time when you know the there's whether
it's about woke stuff or statues or
whatever it is there's always something
and
uh so that is really dispiriting and i
think we'll feel relieved that it hasn't
happened uh similarly i'm i find it hard
to think of some very specific tangible
thing he would try to do but you know i
almost don't want to mention it because
i don't want to give him any ideas but
you wouldn't put it past him that he
would think separation red meat
operation big dog they sort of thing to
be revitalized that's
you never know what he might try and do
i i want to agree with simon on one
thing though and that is this point
about his johnson's removal of a whole
lot of people of talent the eviction of
those 21
you know no people who are against no
deal
it did do something really bad for the
conservative party but in a way also for
the countries it did you know absolutely
shrink the talent pool and one of the
really discreditable things johnson has
done is to have this
cabinet of
um
sort of midgets um
that he that he liked politically
political midgets because he thought it
meant that he could tower above them and
and look better
by having the so many talentless people
around but it means you then don't ha
and it's a sign always a very weak
manager or leader of a team when they
feel they don't want any kind of tall
puppies around them uh he that's what he
did and that that's one of the things
that tory but now have to contend with
which is they don't really have a very
good field to pick from because he got
rid of some of the really
you know one of the person you asked me
who i would like i wouldn't like any of
them but the one person i probably could
have lived with as a conservative prime
minister you know now presents a podcast
with aleister campbell you know rory
stewart is spending his time doing that
and that's because boris johnson got rid
of a lot of the the more talented
figures from his own party
and just very quickly do you think now
that boris johnson is almost gone do you
think the conservative party can become
sort of more of a a broad church again
will it revitalize and and include
elements who sort of felt they had to
leave
it very possibly could um especially if
they have managed to have a leader who
isn't part of the brexit wars and part
of that history i don't know who that
would be um but no they have that chance
and the one thing i would never write
off is the conservative party it is the
most successful election winning machine
in
global political history as far as i
understand it so don't write them off
they always adapt they change shape and
they come back
well we have completely run out of time
but thank you both for for joining us on
this historic day
my thanks to jonathan friedland simon
jenkins to everybody who's tuned in
thanks very much for joining us and to
intelligent squad